ні Панова сьогодні неабиякий день день
благодійника і цілком логічно і
справедливо щоб Сьогодні ми зробили
певний підсумок благодійної роботи
великої команди волонтерів це фонда
Петра Порошенка е корпорація Рошен і
громадська організація справа громад і
сьогодні в найближчий час йтиметься саме
про це
діяльність слів
[музика]
Давайте давайте хлопці їжу давайте сюди
до нас звернувся керівник цього потягу
вони вивозять з Луганської Донецької
областей а по дорозі ще і забрали людей
з Харкова чоловік
в Ірпіні проводимо еваку
[музика]
ацію
дуже любить
Слава Україні
ми до вас приїхали не спустими руками
[музика]
Героям слава Україні
присягаю виконувати свої обов'язки в
інте
ресах сяй ніколи не зрадити українському
народові і відроджена армія
зустріла ворога зустріла агресора так що
здивувало світ Україна переможе в цій
Вітчизняній війні проти російської
Дякую за службу і слава Україні
[оплески]
[музика]
нашого міста про зачистки він буде дуже
корисний
[музика]
машини швидкої допомоги які ми
спрямували в військових шпиталь
машини будемо використовувати для
евакуації поранених
бойових дій People
[музика]
це дуже-дуже для нас потрібно і ми за це
дуже вдячна
[музика]
це є кефір ворог фрукти овочі дуже
скучили за кафиром за молочними
продуктами
Караван наших вантажівок знову іде на
фронт забезпечуємо
збройні сили забезпечуємо підрозділи
територіальних там ви бачите тут біля
сотні броні живуть і тут більше 10 серце
іде десантно-штурмові війська
мотопомпи для відкачування води і троси
і генератори бензинові генератори
дизельні газові балони лопати кірки баки
для води бачите що ми купили пральні
машини
холодильники ми робимо спеціальне
сконструйовані позиції по хімічній
очистці води
[музика]
Слава Україні
продовжувати те що розпочали в 14-му
році
зараз встановлюємо насоси і після
насосів дані очисні споруди будуть
очищувати воду яка буде придатна для
пиття переконаний що ми їх передаєм в
недільні руки
ще раз сердечно Дякуємо
[музика]
бригадами швидкої допомоги то вони
будуть кожного дня приїжджати будуть
збиратися населені які будуть
потребувати медичну допомогу
[музика]
Сьогодні ми в Дніпрі продовольчі набори
і побутова хімія
ми сьогодні ми тут для того щоб помогти
795-57 однозначно великий Дякуємо що
воно треба і воно треба
хлопці склали список і вони Дуже якісно
підготували ми писали по максимуму все
що необхідно і зараз об'єми того що нам
надали Навіть перебільшують наші
очікування ми реально дуже вдячні Це
просто забезпечить нормальний побут і
нормальні позиції для роти для
батальйону зробити все для нашої
Перемоги
[музика]
я дійшла
справа до техніки
навіть було прийняте рішення поставити
нові автомобілі нові пікапи яких
гарантовано проходять декілька років
повнопривідні
потужні і вони в такому вигляді
підуть на фронт
машина нова машина добра нафарширована
повністю супер що це пікап є змога
встановити ззаду ДШК ПТРК все що
завгодно Я вважаю для нашого підрозділу
це супер хочу подякувати на автомобілі
дійсно класні тепер наші завдання будуть
виконуватися набагато ефективністю ми
захищаємо Україну кожен на своєму
потреба в грузовиках постійно машинка
яку ми дуже потребуємо потреба в них
колосальна
прекрасних позашляховика та
акумуляторний батареї для наших
радіостанцій де можна обладнання
помістити їх боєприпаси і пускову
установку вони заряджені статусом країни
як кандидати в члени Європейського Союзу
Все буде добре Ми переможемо обов'язково
Тим паче з такою допомогою надходить
постійно Зверніть сили
наших воїнів
і з нульовим пробігом всі вони підуть
десантно-штурмове військо
[музика]
це мобільність в першу чергу
це буде Україна
ці вантажівки які будуть завантажувати
боєприпаси
Це перша партія яку пофарбували змінили
кузов зробили то зробили позицію
технічного обслуговування для все
особисто
ще багато разів бачитися бо на цьому
наші співпраця з бригадою не зупиняється
три місяці підготовки офіційні ліцензії
контракти рішення урядів І от нарешті я
по-перше в Україні сучасну іноземну
бойову техніку для збройних сил купують
волонтери і благодійники 11 бронемобілів
для десанту 11 бойових машин для наступу
справжніх супергероїв кожен зараз в цих
умовах робить Просто те що він може для
того щоб наблизити перемогу
[оплески]
[музика]
ця машина буде сприяти наші Перемоги
Дякую
новітні автомобілі 2007 зрозуміло він
нас не підведе
ми спільно це зробили
[музика]
сьогодні вже і передаються дрони
Посейдон які літають на висоті 5 тисяч
метрів які бачать на відстані 15
кілометрів проєкт Посейдон і це все
дорогі друзі робимо ми з вами Україна
переможемо
[музика]
сьогодні Україна відправляються оцих
Дронів які так потрібні нашим військовим
[музика]
хочу особисто і від особового складу 95
окремих десантно-штурмової бригади
подякувати Сьогодні ми маємо рвонути цю
штангу допомогти збройним силам
підтримати збройні сили то вони є
найкраще в світі Для успішного ударного
контрнаступку
152-й ми передаємо бригаду збройних сил
України
вже завтра вони будуть робити смерть
ворогам
Я вже бачу Івана нам дуже потрібне
харківщина перемагає і завдяки отаким от
важливим таким військовим речім
[музика]
дальний бойовий робот який здатний буде
забезпечувати і розміщення автоматичної
30-міліметрової гармати і протитанкової
системи включно стугною або джевеліном і
розвідувальної системи включно з радаром
ці роботи вже стоять на озброєнні трьох
армій країн членів НАТО і сьогодні
вперше це бойова техніка майбутнього
з'явилася в Україні і ми думаємо вона
зробить величезна потужний внесок для
нашої Перемоги
[музика]
і справді сьогодні ми будемо говорити
багато про ті речі які були зроблені
благодійниками волонтерами меценатами за
півроку титанічної праці і цілком
справедливо якщо там перше слово п'ятий
президент України Петро Порошенко я
дякую вам за це Дякую Віталію дорогі
друзі Я хотів би приєднатися і привітати
тих хто не залишився байдужим тих хто
може з гордістю носити
високе Звання волонтера і які з 24
лютого спочатку повномасштабного
російського вторгнення довели ми всі без
виключення солдати і зараз немає справи
важливішою ніж захист нашої Вітчизни
і 24 Ми всі були готові Кожен з нас знав
чітко своє місцезнав чітко своє завдання
я окремо хочу згадати тут про сотні
наших активістів які негайно в той же
день стали долав збройних сил України і
вони хоробро б'ються на різних ділянках
фронту чистіми словами
На жаль я
маю схилити разом з вами голову бо
багато з них як наші Юра Каракай
Гліб Бабич Тарас жеребецький і
багато-багато інших
віддали своє життя в боротьбі проти
рашинських агресорів вічна їм пам'ять
ніколи не забудемо ніколи не пробачимо
російського
ми зосередили свої зусилля на трьох
напрямках парламенті Наша команда
неухильно дотримуються принципу
внутрішньої єдності і головні ініціативи
та рішення для нас ті які стосуються
підтримки держави збройних сил
волонтерів ветеранів родин загиблих і
поранених
і ще один пріоритет другий це зміцнення
міжнародної підтримки України
практично щоденних інтерв'ю західним
медіа доводимо до суспільства
імпартнерів що допомога Україні в їхніх
інтересах чи тільки разом ми Здолаємо
російську агресора І що тільки перемога
України принесе надійний мир для всієї
Європи і врешті-решт для всього світу
Всі робочі контакти мої весь вплив і
свій авторитет в Євросоюзі Сполучених
Штатів Америки ми використовуємо для
допомоги України як економічної так і
військової
і третя Але найголовніше завдання
зробити все для постачання озброєння
засобів захисту бронетехніки
безпілотніков і багато-багато іншого для
збройних сил України а з чого ми
починали
негайне оснащення всім необхідним
батальйонів територіальної оборони Києва
в тому числі і створені тут на нашій
базі переросло в низку проектів на
користь тепер вже можна казати про це
багатьох частин збройних сил пам'ятаємо
як на початку весни не було нічого ні
бронежилетів ні касах шоломів ні форми і
навіть білизни і Я переконаний що ті хто
зірвали постачання засобів захисту
несправедливо тримали у в'язниці
Генерала кіборга марченка вони ще будуть
відповідати за своїх діверсії але війна
не час злотішатися і тому ми закупили а
згодом і налагодили виробництво де це
було можливим тисячі засобів захисту для
наших українських воїнів і від емоції До
засобів захисту доволі швидко
перемкнулися ми на зброю на військове
спорядження ручні кулемети гранати
радіостанції все що потребували з перших
днів бійці територіальної оборони Києва
та Збройних сил ми знаходили
викуповували за власні гроші і постачали
до армії на фронті часто телеве
забезпечення генератори система очистки
води навіть бензопили звичайні лопати на
вагу золота і ми знаємо І лише Минулого
тижня наші команди закупили 80
генераторів щоб ви знали як раділи наше
хлопці І як важко вона їх знаходили бо
це є дизельні потужністю 6,5 кВт з
системою глушників і ними можна закрити
потреби штабів батальйонів багатьох
бригад і вже вересень зима близько і
зараз ми починаємо викупати дуже просту
річ пічки буржуйки
найголовніше для нас рятувати життя і
тому один з найсильніших наголосів
робимо на медичному забезпеченні Марина
Порошенко Як ви знаєте лікар і Тож вона
координує проекти з постачання
документів і медичного спорядження
уявить у війська була передана лише
аптечок натівського зразка на 330
мільйонів гривень і додатково що ліки
необхідних категорій машини швидкої
допомоги зокрема броньовані броня на
фронті потрібно скрізь прийняти це ключ
для нашого з вами Контрнаступ це ключове
слово для очищення наших земель від
ворога Ми отримали контракт закупили
доставили в Україну і вже передали
десантникам 11 найсучасніших італійських
броньовиків шилд і вони вже в бою ще
будуть британські БМП Спартан і на них
вже отримані британські ліцензії чекаємо
зараз транзитних ліцензій вони вже
оплачені
це вже не кажучи про сотні
повнопривідних військових вантажівок
також уже з ліцензіями десятки пікапів
тягачі для перевезення надважкої
натівської бронетехніки всі ці механізми
коліщатка нашого наступу і нашої
перемоги бо перемога України над ворогом
який накопичив десятки тисяч тонн
вбивчого заліза і суне ним на нашу землю
це перевага у розумі перевага
технологіях і тому поруч з колісною і
гусенічною технікою ми зараз приділяємо
увагу оснащенню майбутнього це наш з
вами проект
очі-арти комплекс оперативних
безпілотників Посейдон здатних проривати
ворожі засоби радіоелектронної боротьби
і коригувати вогонь нашої артилерії
здалека і точно на цій
в порівнянні з ними невеличкі дрони для
взводів здаються буденністю але це
робочі пташки які допомагають воїну
орієнтуватися довкола своїх позицій і ми
вже віддали військо понад 350 таких
Дронів і стандарти НАТО і військові
традиції України передбачають що життя
воїна на полі бою має бути максимально
захищена тож З цією метою ми спільно з
Яною Зінкевич з госпітальєром
розпочинаємо проект евакуатора
поранених з переднього краю
представимо його найближчим часом ми
передаємо для цього
надсучасної робот для евакуації та
розвідки який значно підвищать шанси на
порятунок наших воїнів це проект
німецького естонського виробництва який
стоїть вже на озброєнні трьох країн НАТО
але він конче необхідний Україні і лише
уявити собі росіяни і навіть не бачили А
що оголосили винагороду мільйон тому хто
зможе її захопити в більш-менш цілому
вигляді і передати до Міноборони Росії а
втім Я переконаний що наші воїни не
дозволять ворогу отримати доступ до
секретів цієї техніки
шановне товариство зрештою міцний фронт
тримається на міцному тиловому
забезпеченні ми спрямували колосальні
зусилля на допомогу постраждалим на
постачання всього необхідного щодня як
для фронту так і для громад постраждалих
від війни я хочу подякувати всю нашу
команду бо
логістика збір коштів
організація постачання
а також на основі місцевих організацій
європейської солідарності було
розгорнуто 142 волонтерських Хаба і
через них проходить тонне вантажів
десятки сотні тонн від продуктів до
мастувальних сіток які вони плитуть А
чим і як рахувати допомогу для тисячі
тисяч наших співвітчизників ми збилися
рахувати рейси кілометри та нас ще в
квітні Але ми не втомилися простягати
руку підтримки ця чуйність теж є частина
нашої з вами спільної боротьби за
перемогу наше завдання продовжувати і
розгортати цю боротьбу а зробити це було
не просто і ключове слово для нас ще раз
Хочу повторити
Контрнаступ цим зараз живуть всі
українці
і не вірте він успішно розвивається хто
б що не говорив І саме Контрнаступ
збройних сил
визначити подальший вхід війни а для
успіху потрібно ще більше ресурсів
і тому нам зараз належить підтримати
наших бійців у критично важливих точках
і в місцях найгарячіших боїв і в вузлах
логістичних проблем це наше завдання
завдання справи громад завдання братів
по зброї вони зосередиться на його
вирішення і доля України доля кожного з
нас вирішується тепер на фронті Ми
зробимо все що в наших силах щоб
зміцнити збройні сили України перед
вирішальними боями
здобуваємо перемогу разом в єдності
переможемо я хочу подякувати тим сотням
і тисячам людей які були залучені в
організації системи допомоги від справи
громад
І подякувати тим десяткам тисяч людей
які відгукуються на наші заклики
включаються в цю допомогу грошима
волонтерською працею разом Ми переможемо
ворог дуже важливо що від тих хто
опинився за кордоном і вони знаходять
можливості посилають нам гривні до тих
хто вже не має грошей але своєю роботою
водіями вантажниками організаторами
беруть участь в нашій спільній справі ми
разом переможемо ворога перемога Буде за
нами Слава Україні Героям слава україні
і з вашого дозволу з дозволу глядачів
напевно надзвичайно важливо розставити
акценти цієї віхи Це абсолютно точно не
фінальні цифри які ми зараз вам озвучимо
І я б хотів би можливо кілька разів
сьогодні наголосити на одному
дуже важливим моменті якщо
проаналізувати всі проекти які були
здійснені разом окремо і фондом Петра
Порошенка і корпорацію Ярошенко і
справою громад то в публічному просторі
було
80% цих проектів відсутні їх було є вони
невідомі вони невідомі в публічному
просторі але вони є в житті і це просто
великий привіт всім тим які закидали і
Мені особисто я думаю Петрові Порошенко
що мовляв хтось
багато говорить про свою благі справи Ні
небагато рівно стільки скільки треба із
вашого дозволу підкріплю цю впевненість
цифрами і першою буде 1 млрд
234 мільйони 145 тисяч
284 гривні за півроку фонд Порошенка
корпорація Рошен і справа громад себто і
ваші гроші також ми передали допомогу на
цю суму зараз я хотів би наголосити і з
величезними словами подяки тим хто
донатив справу громад різними сумами там
були і 50 і 150 грн і 1050 і тисячі і
десятки тисяч будь ласка покажіть
наступний слайд
147 000 147 мільйонів
669.356 Це ваші гроші які були скеровані
на закупівлю надзвичайно важливих речей
для збройних сил України Ця допомога Ян
Оголошую вона була не тільки закуплена а
це те що вже доставлено до адресатів і
дещо згодом ми закцентуємо на тих
проектах Які ще знаходяться в розвитку і
будуть завершені в вересні в жовтні до
нового року А окремі великі будуть
тягнутися ще і на наступний рік
для того щоб зрозуміти обсяг цих цифр
будь ласка наступну картинку покажіть
порівняйте зараз ви бачите
обсяги допомоги яка надавалася на рівні
держав різних держав ви бачите і
Сполучені Штати і там природньо сума в
мільярдах доларів ви бачите країни
Європи і великі і малі які могли
надавати допомогу просто там там Литва
на рівні 15 мільйонів доларів там
Британія там 577 мільйонів я це згадую
лише з однієї причини що ви Зверніть
увагу що громадяни України надали
допомогу у валютному
еквіваленті на рівні з 45 мільйонів
995 тисяч доларів
України тільки а ми всі разом як
громадяни України і тут наголосити що це
і меценати великі це і великий бізнес
нашої команди і ви люди які відривали з
власної зі своє в кишені і скеровували
на корисну справу і ось тут я б знову
нагадав би про
80% про що не розказувалося але це
робилося робилося тому що треба я вам
прошу показати наступну цифру
Напевно вона звучить І показується
вперше з
2014 року 3 мільярди 600 мільйонів
гривень станом на
24 серпня цього року саме стільки було
передано нашою командою на допомогу
збройним силам України зафіксуйте будь
ласка тому що далі буде стосовно далі
пане президентом можливо варто щоб ви
відкрили деякі історії які вже почали
вироблятися Покажіть будь ласка наступну
картинку
звичайно ми живемо нашими планами на
майбутнє звичайно ми мріємо щоб
прискорити їх реалізацію але вже
сьогодні я можу наголошувати що проект
Посейдон з оперативними безпілотниками
які
називаються очі арти і який спільно з
правою громад дозволяє наші
артилерійський розвідки по всьому
фронтові бачити і знищувати російські
склади боєприпасів російські скупчення
техніки і живої сили російські штаби і
Ми приємно враження що це мрія яку нам
висловлюють підрозділи збройних сил
України і оперативного рівня керування
більше 200 вантажних військових
автомобілів більшість з яких буде
використана як артилерійський тягачі в
тому числі і для Західної натівської
артилерії з боєприпасами з кранами які
будуть вантажити це також проект який
коштує більше двох мільйонів функтів і
знов кажу під них вже отримане ліцензія
і він буде реалізовуватися в найближчі
тижні або місяці і ми обмежені лише
можливості перевезення з складів
тривалого зберігання Британії до України
і Я закликаю наших партнерів наших
друзів хто може допомогти з перевезенням
з Британії до Польщі до України нам ваша
допомога буде конче і кончі потрібно тим
хто має порожній зворотній отримані рейс
до України прохання Вийдіть будь ласка
на зв'язок до
наших друзів справи громад третя позиція
ми починаємо дуже круту презентацію
робота перший робот вже закуплений
проект називається журавель він буде
присвячений
можливості евакуації з переднього краю
ми зараз його бронюємо ми вдосконалюємо
систему управління і дуже сподіваємося
проект називається проект журавель
присвячений нашому герою який загинув на
Донбасі і я дуже дякую госпітальєрам які
зголосилися стати нашим партнером по
цьому проекту ми будемо завозити і
броньовані
Вакула евакуатори пінгауер також вже
перше за контрактована і буде надходити
до госпіта
і ми маємо величезну величезну комплекс
нашої співпраці включно з тим про що я
не казав і поки що говорити не буду з
підтримкою нашої сил протиповітряної
оборони ми це робимо з 14-го року без
зайвого розголосу А це залишається серед
наших пріоритетів і я обіцяю що ми вас
Будемо дуже регулярно інформувати для
того щоби подякувати бо кожна ваша
гривня яку ви вкладаєте на рахунок
справи громад точно доєднується і наша з
Мариною гривня яка вдвічі збільшує
ефективність ваших коштів з більш
кількість зброї яка надходить ми
закупаємо по найнижчим цінам і в
найкоротші терміни доставляємо на фронт
бо зараз ще раз кажу слово на яке ми
маємо молитися слово В яке ми маємо
вірити слово на яке ми маємо сподіватися
- це відбувається Контр наступ збройних
сил і саме сьогодні І саме зараз збройні
сили потребують нашої з вами підтримки
ми це зробимо Ми переможемо Слава
Україні Героям слава і я просто зафіксую
ще раз тому що це важливо за півроку
благодійної діяльності фонду Петра
Порошенка корпорація Рошен та нашої
громадської організації справа громад
завдяки нашим спільним зусиллям Було
зібрано грошей закуплено надзвичайно
потрібних обладнання зброї все те що
потребує збройних сил України на 45
мільйонів
995 тисяч доларів і насправді це
унікальна пропозиція коли на кожну вашу
гривню фон Петра Порошенка додає стільки
ж
Я дуже хотів наголосити що всю цю
величезну роботу робить наша команда і
значна частина лягає на цій красиві
грубки плечі Марини Порошенко Я дуже
дякую і ми
спільнотипляємося розраховуємо на вашу
підтримку і вдячні за все що ви робите
так
це наша спільна робота і я думаю що ми
будемо ще разом робити дуже багато
потрібних справ
до кінця і до перемоги
Спасибі вам спасибі Вам
[музика]